the fox cut is the new season chop you
need to know about it follows a whole
pack of animal inspired haircuts but
this one is like the Glam little sis to
the wolf cut the wolf cut was all about
Shaggy layers and while the fox cut
still centers around layers they're
longer more subtle and deliberately
structural they frame the cheekbone
Jawbone and clavicle if you want
something polished that's still
voluminous this gives a sleeker 90s
blow-dried Vibe Top London Hair Stylist
Jordana Cabela explained the fox cut has
merged as an evolved and sophisticated
version of the wolf cut offering a more
subtle yet glamorous look so if you're
looking for another take on layers the
fox cut is the one to watch